economía en france 24 me acompaña en el
estudio daniela blandón daniela buena
noche bienvenida a la presidencia de
ecuador llega un ex banquero con la
promesa de bajar los impuestos sí señor
raúl muy buenas noches la primera
promesa del conservador guillermo lazo
es de reactivar una economía golpeada
por varios años de austeridad y sin
solvencia damos un repaso por sus
principales cuentas según datos
oficiales ecuador vive un déficit fiscal
desde 2009
desde ese momento el país no puede
cubrir sus gastos con los ingresos que
obtiene como vemos en el gráfico la
deuda pública ya supera los 60 mil
millones de dólares y abarca más del 65
por ciento del pib una proporción
bastante alta para hacer de la región de
ese total ecuador debe pagar en los
próximos cuatro años más de 39 mil
millones de dólares ahora veamos sus
propuestas las obtendrá que renegociar
la deuda y buscar nuevas fuentes de
financiación el mandatario quiere
impulsar una reforma tributaria otras de
sus promesas son renegociar contratos
petroleros y mineros
también reducir el gasto público y
adicionalmente en materia de empleo el
nuevo presidente quiere generar 2
millones de puestos de trabajo y subir a
500 dólares el salario mínimo así como
también acabar con el hambre de más de
un millón de ciudadanos entre otras y
esperemos saber entonces en estos 4 años
que puede lograr de esta forma de sajan
y el eje 7 está ultimando detalles para
establecer un puesto corporativo global
del que hemos venido hablando mucho
últimamente raúl pesa dorada según el
financial times el plan está listo para
ser lanzado el viernes por los ministros
de finanzas del g7 después 135 naciones
tendrían que negociarlo en el seno de la
organización para la cooperación y el
desarrollo económico la ocde o conocida
como el club de países ricos la
propuesta que viene de la administración
estadounidense de joe biden pretende que
las grandes multinacionales sean
gravadas con un 15 por cierto sobre sus
ganancias todavía no se conocen todos
los detalles de la iniciativa pero
francia alemania italia y japón ya le
dieron el sí
reino unido ha sido un poco más
cauteloso pues habrá una próxima cumbre
de ministros de finanzas del grupo de
los siete entre el 4 y 5 de junio en
donde se esperan pues nuevos avances en
este tema y una de las minas de carbón
más grandes del mundo daniela suspendió
su operación le preguntó a qué se debe
bueno estamos hablando de la mina
colombiana carbones del cerrejón que es
la más grande del país y una de las más
grandes operaciones a cielo abierto del
mundo este lunes suspendió sus
operaciones de raúl por cuenta del
desabastecimiento de combustibles la
empresa dice que llegó a esta situación
por dos bloqueos que tilda de ilegales
el primero comenzó el 5 de mayo sobre la
línea férrea por la que se transporta el
carbón este es liderado dice por un
grupo de ex trabajadores que se re hong
despidió en febrero aumentando
argumentando fuerza mayor sin tratar con
que es su sindicato lo llamó una masacre
laboral y convocó a nuevas
movilizaciones este miércoles también
para unirse al paro nacional que avanza
desde hace varios días por otro lado el
jueves 20 de mayo miembros de una de las
comunidades
e influencia de la mina bloquearon la
entrada a sus instalaciones exigiendo
empleos por lo que ningún vehículo puede
salir del puerto está compañía ha tenido
muchos desencuentros con las comunidades
indígenas de la zona raúl y el año
pasado de hecho cerró sus minas por
cuenta de una huelga de tres meses
daniela hay una nueva batalla en la
guerra arancelaria entre eeuu y reino
unido bueno el ministerio de comercio
británico sacó a comentario es un
proyecto con el que busca imponer nuevos
aranceles al vino el chocolate y las
langostas que provienen de eeuu en el
marco de una interminable batalla
comercial que casi cumple dos décadas el
ex presidente de donald trump introdujo
gravámenes del 25 del 10 por ciento al
acero y el aluminio británicos en
represalia la unión europea de la que
reinó unido- formado parte grabó bienes
como las motocicletas el whisky o el
trabajo ahora que no está en el bloque
reino unido está en conversaciones con
la casa blanca para eliminar aranceles
mutuamente pero mientras no se llegue a
ningún acuerdo sus planes impositivos
siguen adelante indicadores wall street'
de seropositivo gracias a una buena
jornada
de las acciones tecnológicas las
acciones europeas se mantienen cerca de
máximos históricos también con las
acciones tecnológicas a la cabeza y el
positivismo llegó a américa latina con
excepción de méxico que perdió 0,6 por
ciento y para final rápidamente cifra el
cifra el día en 30% ha bajado el consumo
de animales salvajes en países donde
esta práctica es habitual durante la
pandemia esto según una encuesta de la
organización medioambiental wwf una
buena cifra niela gracias por la
información a ustedes también gracias
continúen con nosotros
[Música]